Speaker 1: An anti transgender mom was interviewed
on CNN. It is extraordinarily disturbing and sad.
And I'm going to play it for you. And we're going
to talk through some of the things that were said.
This is Darcy showing the chapter chair for Moms
for Liberty in El Paso County, Colorado. Darcy
is very, very worried. She's worried that there
are multiple forces at play that want to convince
our children to become gay or trans, which I
feel like a moron even saying, because anybody
who understands being gay or trans realizes that
this concept makes absolutely no sense, nor does
the nor do any of the parties mentioned have any
interest in convincing people to be gay or trans.
However, what I would I do want to point to in
this interview is the interviewer, Elle Reeve
asks, Why would teachers unions or BYD, why would
they want to convince people to be gay or trans?
Darcy has an answer. It's an idiotic answer. It's
an easily debunked answer. It's an answer that
makes no sense whatsoever unless you understand
nothing about anything. But she has an answer,
so we're going to be able to analyze it for what
it is. All right. Let's take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: Behind your parents back. I
got your back. I mean, there's a clear
move to bring more of that into our school
than it's just not the school's place. So
what I feel like you're strongly implying,
and I would like to get your take on,
because I don't want to attribute something that
you don't dig. But to me, it sounds like you're
saying there's some kind of high level coordinated
effort to make more children trans and gay. Yeah.
Well, who's directing the teachers unions and
our presidents and a lot of funding sources and.
Speaker 1: Which she doesn't
mention. So that's teachers unions.
Our president, which at least she acknowledges
Biden is the president, teachers unions, Biden and
a lot of funding sources want to make kids gay.
Speaker 2: And trans unions are also
heavily backing the curriculum that
we're bringing into school. Why would
they want more kids to be gay and straight?
Because it breaks down the family unit,
which breaks down traditional conservative values.
It breaks down a lot of things in this country.
It changes the way that people think. It changes
the way that people handle politics. Of course,
there's no evidence of a coordinated plot to make
kids trans. When I hear those thoughts about,
like some sort of concerted effort to
make people gay, does it sound like a
conspiracy theory to you? It's not a conspiracy
theory that this state, whether you're talking
about Colorado or the federal government,
is taking a stronger and stronger hand in
public education in raising our kids.
Speaker 1: There's a big jump from that
to what she's claiming.
Speaker 2: So do I think that
for some reason, people want everyone to be gay?
That's a mischaracterized translation of what I
think. I think that people will use, you know, the
people that want to erode away at parental rights,
the left, the teachers unions. They'll use
LGBTQ or whatever may be the case at the time.
Speaker 1: Those are. Yeah. So she's like, it's
not that they want to make everyone gay or trans.
They just want to make a lot more people gay and
trans. And the critical line from this is she
says that because it's a good question, right? Why
would anyone want to do this? What's the political
goal in making more people, gay and trans kids,
if you could do such a thing? And she says it
will break down the family unit and it will break
down conservative values. Well, what's interesting
about I mean, think that through, right? If
you have a child and the child is gay, it
only breaks down the family unit. If the parents
reject the kid and kick them out of the house,
which sometimes happens, Right. When you actually
think about what she's saying, you realize that's
only the case if we treat LGBT folks terribly,
including LGBT kids. So let's go through a
couple of these these ideas here. First is the
notion that teachers unions have adopted this
secret mission to undermine the family unit and
conservative values by trying to convince children
to take on these identities. There's no evidence
of that. But the suggestion would make you
believe or suggest to you that educators who go
through all of the schooling that they go through
bachelor's degree, typically master's degree, they
learn how to teach, how to impart knowledge, how
to educate young minds, all of these things, their
actual plan all along was to be social engineers,
to get themselves into classrooms in order to
convince children to be gay, specifically to
tear families apart by destroying the family unit
through such social engineering. That's an insane
thing to accuse teachers of doing because you
have to. When they vaguely say the teachers union,
you think of this monolith, this almost like a
corporation of sorts, but then you think through
it. You go, Oh, okay. The third grade teacher
who is now in debt because of the master's in
education that they have and they're underpaid and
blah, blah, blah, they did all of it. Not because
they genuinely want to teach kids, but because
they have this clandestine mission to turn kids
gay and trans. And that's how they want to shape
the country through social engineering. It's an
outrageous thing to suggest. Then there's, well,
Biden wants the same thing. I mean, if if anything
can be said about Joe Biden, it's that his focus
on LGBT issues has not been overwhelming. I mean,
yes, he's done a couple events at the White House
and welcomed people or whatever. He's treating
people with respect. But the idea that that's
Biden's goal, but also the idea that that this
alleged obsessive focus on turning people, kids,
gay and trans by Biden would gain him political
capital when it's known to be such a controversial
issue thanks to right wingers, that doesn't make
any sense in any way. And then lastly, she throws
in this and there are also funding sources that
want more gay and trans people. She doesn't
name those sources, I think unless she does,
it's very hard to take it seriously. But you
have to understand what's at this core. A very
benign and milquetoast sort of declaration that
we should treat people with respect. We should
have basic inclusivity in schools when it comes to
LGBT people. That's what's really going on. Like,
let's treat people with respect. In some places
we have to figure out what to do about bathrooms
because it's like a tactical issue, A practical
issue. Yes. And some there are some sports related
questions to figure out. But basically what we're
saying is let's let everybody feel comfortable
and let's prevent people from feeling under threat
based on their identity, because that's what
gives those folks. And as a result, society as a
whole the greater chance to flourish and provide
everybody equal rights and opportunities under the
law. That's that's all that's going on. And they
see that as an attack. They see it as an attack
on, quote, conservative values. They see it as an
attack on the, quote, family unit. As Darcy shown
says in this interview. That's what this is really
about, leveling the playing field so that it's
not openly okay to discriminate against minority
groups they see as an attack. And that tells
you a lot about what these folks are thinking.